we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
really interesting voicemail regarding
interviews with extremists that we've
done on the program before take a listen
to this
hey David this is Cameron from DC and
you might be interested to know I
actually came familiar with you and your
fantastic show by watching Jesse Lee
Peterson videos because I hate myself
and I was thinking you know on your show
you've had Richard Spencer Jordan
Peterson you know people are various
neoconservatives their various religious
radicals and I'm just wondering you know
you get times criticized dave rubin for
his sort of radical centrism ancestors
at what point would you say that i all
right now I'm abusing my power and I
should not be giving this crackpot a
platform at what point would you make
that distinction anyone pick better this
show very good excellent questions so
here's so the question is I interview
extremists and then sometimes I don't
and sometimes I will have an extremists
on several times in a row for a period
of time and then we never hear from them
again
there's no set answer basically it's a
judgment call and what I evaluate at any
given time when thinking about whether
I'm going to have an extremist on is
number one
can I responsibly platform them in other
words am I prepared to push back against
their extreme and really bad ideas if
the answer is yes then the next question
is are they representing a significant
enough perspective that it's worth
exposing it or are we better off just
ignoring it so if we think back to like
eight nine years ago when gay marriage
which was a much bigger debate the
Westboro Baptist Church known for their
horrible slogan God hates [ __ ] they were
having much more of a public presence
they were protesting funerals they were
on national media they were much more
worthy of refuting than they are now so
it's been years since we had the
Westboro Baptist Church people on the
program because I just don't think
they're even worth our time to refute
anymore there was this crazy anti-gay
chaplain from Colorado named Gordon
and Schmidt who is well at one point was
a state representative and there was a
point at which his notoriety and the
prevalence of his views were such that I
believed it was a worthwhile effort to
have him on and to attempt to expose him
and to counteract those views I don't
know where he's gone he's disappeared
but it's no longer interesting or useful
to have to have them on so it's an
evaluation of any particular extremists
in terms of are we better off exposing
that these are ideologies that exist are
they so small that it's not even worth
it and what is there to potentially
achieve by bringing them onto the
program and talking about whatever their
issue is so the answer is it's a it's a
gray area and you just kind of know it
when you see it it's clear right now
that there's no point in having the
Westboro Baptist Church people on would
you know other extremists it just
depends on who it is you're thinking
about but it's something that I evaluate
on a regular basis when we think about
guests on the show we've got a great
bonus show for you today I'm out of time
I can't tell you what's on it but it's
really good and I look forward to
speaking to you then